hi so uh i just texted my dad to ask  about my canadian citizenship because my  brother um applied for his because  apparently that's something that i have  that i can do  kind of cool but anyways i just attested  to apply for mine  because i didn't have any interest in it  like a couple months ago but now i'm  [ __ ] terrified to live in this  [ __ ] country because i'm so  over it  um  because i hate my town and i hate the  country in general and that's just on  hating america  she will be sorely missed stop don't  come back what will this country do  without her so really she's on drugs  right isn't that the the first clue is  that she's moving to canada  and the second is that she's babbling  incoherently in what way is canada an  improvement it's canada question one do  you want to be canadian question two  really what problems do you find here  that you won't find there she has no  answers for those questions obviously  all she knows is that she hates it here